Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
I'm for
form.
Alma,
[Silence]
so in The spirit regarding the virtues
of knowledge
at half of the Noah mentions an
narration that
I wish we could really take to heart and
embrace with true conviction.
Imagine how different our world would be
if we really took only what we already
know, no new knowledge, just what every
one of us already knows and embraced it
fully without hesitation and with total
conviction.
Right? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
Enter into Islam entirely, completely,
wholeheartedly. Don't half step. No half
measures. What do half measures look
like? What does hesitation
look like? I'll give you a number of
examples.
A person is going to come to J,
but there's hesitation,
but the person is distracted.
So they come late. They fail to do the
extras that make our acceptable to
Allah.
They do the bare minimum and then stoop
below that
come to J but come a little bit late and
then when we're in Jum we look at our
phone a couple times. We check our
email. you know, we don't want the world
to pass us by while we're just sitting
in the masid, right?
And so, we neither are living out in the
world,
nor are we in
we're in some bizarre middle ground
where we manage to miss out on both.
A person comes to salah, they start
their salah, Allahbar, their heart
creeps out and runs off to everywhere
else in the world except for the masid,
except for the moment they are in. So
their tongue is saying alhamdulillah
and their heart and mind is somewhere
completely else.
A person
wishes to
wishes to fast.
And so in fasting what do we do? We
refrain from eating and drinking. We
refrain from intimacy with our
with our wives or our husbands. And
that is it.
The remainder, nothing changes
whatsoever about our behavior. We don't
change the way that we see the world. We
don't change the way that we speak. We
don't change the way that we act. As a
matter of fact, because of the vices and
because of the addictions that we have,
we cannot bear to live in the moment of
fasting. We just want it to be done.
just let me get through this, get this
out of the way, get it over with. Let me
get my cigarette. Let me get my coffee.
Let me get my whatever it is and be done
with this. Now, the person is where
they're in a middle ground
where they're neither fasting nor have
they broken their fast. How does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala treat this? How does
he
deal with this? Well, when a person
fails to do these things,
their salah will be technically valid
cuz they technically made salah.
But they will be rewarded
nothing or very little for their prayer.
Why? Because the prophet sallallah.aii
tells us
The only thing that you will be rewarded
on in your salah is that which you were
present for
that which you were conscious of.
Everything else you you technically
prayed. I technically prayed. You can't
say you didn't pray. Well, technically
the person came and put his body in the
masid,
hit the autopilot and then left the left
the
imam here making salah.
And this, you know, manifest in a number
of ways. I remember one time
I was leading salah in New York City.
I was reciting the end verses
of
[Silence]
and then the people behind me said
that's a true story.
As a matter of fact, I actively avoid
reciting those verses. There's a few of
them in the Quran because I'm afraid
people behind me are going to say,
"Why?"
And I've read this in books before of
this happening.
A few of my Messiah told me that it
happened to them. It's hard to believe
until it happens. Why? Because this is
autopilot,
right?
If you're going to commit to coming to
Jum, come to J. If you're going to
commit to making salah, make salah.
That is going to change everything. If I
were to say to you right now,
Every one of us knows it, right?
How many of us truly
embrace this and do it?
I don't have a single thing that I am
proud of or love except that I wish that
every Muslim had it as well. And I do my
best to make it actualized for my Muslim
brothers and sisters. Imagine.
We all know it. What does that look
like? That looks if there is any
way for me to assume good
in something that could be interpreted
as good or bad, I will always go to the
good for my brother.
That's what that looks like. Now, why
don't we do this? Well, because we're
afraid. We don't want to be the fool,
right? I don't want to be the fool. I
don't want to be the guy that's, you
know, sitting there giving everyone a
free pass while they walk all over me.
Good. So now we are neither
Machavevelian kufur nor are we fully
Muslim. We're somewhere in the middle.
And mediocrity is forgettable.
Everyone forgets mediocrity.
As a matter of fact, mediocrity is
deplorable.
It's looked down upon by human beings.
If I told you we're going to go to a
basketball game, this isn't the pros and
this isn't beginners. This is the most
mediocre basketball players to ever step
onto the court. Would you want to go to
that game? Does that sound exciting?
Nothing amazing will be seen, nor will
it be comedic and silly because they're
all beginners. It's just going to be
just mediocre. Just it's not going to be
good. It's not going to be bad.
Nobody wants mediocrity.
And as the human being forgets
mediocrity,
so do the believers. So does history. So
does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
if you are
satisfied with mediocrity
that is a a very bad situation
and so embracing
full fully in this narration the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
only two types of people are worthy of
your envy.
Only two, no one else.
No matter what it is, you are never to
look at this person and say, "I wish I
had that." Never. Only two people, only
two instances, two situations, two
states are worthy of your envy.
Everything else
is overlooked.
The first is a man,
a person whom Allah has given wealth to.
Now, so far we're all really good at
this part, right? Being envious of a
person whom Allah has given wealth to.
We've got that pretty well done. But
there's only one type of person who's
been given wealth because wealth on its
own is not good enough. It doesn't
benefit you unless
you concentrate it on good. Spending it
for the sake of Allah as if you're
trying to get rid of it.
person may say she but if I spend my
money that and I'm not fiscally
responsible
with my with my donations
then you know I'm going to suffer we're
afraid we're afraid we're afraid to
fulfill the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
he said I swear by Allah
if I had the mountain of in gold. It
would not last 3 days before it being
completely given away.
He gestured with his hand this. I
would give it away this and this
and this. 3 days it would be entirely
gone. The mountain of and gold.
But wait a minute. What about your
family?
What about this and that? This is
what a shaitan whispers.
Shaitan whispers, "Hey, if you give,
you're going to go poor." And that's the
time when it is most important to give.
When the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was asked about the best, the best
charity, what did he say?
He said, formill.
[Silence]
He says the best charity is the charity
that you give when you're healthy,
when you feel most
advert to giving.
When you have in your heart the most
stinginess, you're almost wealthy. You
can taste it. You can see it. You've got
it all planned out. When you are most
afraid of being broke
when you are most stingy, when you feel
that you wish you that that you this is
the hardest thing you could do, that's
the best charity to give it at that
moment
because why?
Because the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
He said,
"I swear by Allah that no charity has
ever depleted a person's wealth ever."
Do you believe? That's why it's called
So to wrap up,
embracing entirely, allowing yourself
to let go. It's hard to do. Don't think
that it's easy for me. I didn't come out
of my mother's womb in the operating
room with a copy of the musaf in my
right hand and a copy of Sah Bkari in my
left. That's not how I was born, by the
way. I worked and I worked in factories
and I have been very very poor before
and I have been very very wealthy before
and the same things that we are all
going through every human being has gone
through. My struggles are not special.
They're special to me but they're not
special. Every one of you has stories
it.
But if you look at your history,
look at your history and look at how
Allah has treated you thus far.
Have you ever truly gone
hungry?
Have you ever truly
been left by Allah, abandoned?
Has Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala ever
mistreated you? More importantly, the
things you fear the most, have they ever
really happened to you?
Because that's what fear is, right? It's
always worse in your mind.
It's always worse in your mind.
It's always worse in your mind. And it's
never as bad as you're afraid it's going
to be. So if you do something, embrace
it. Trust the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam trust Allah have to let go
when's the last time you stood for salah
and lost track of the time I mean lost
track of the time you have no clue what
time it is you could have been standing
for an hour you could have been standing
for 5 minutes when's the last time that
happened when's the last time you lost
track of time talking with someone
when's the last time you lost track of
time watching a movie. See, we are
capable of doing it, but it's what we do
it for.
If you allow yourself to fall, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will catch you and
he will raise you. But if we stay
hesitating, we'll never get anywhere.
We will never get the hereafter in its
totality and we will miss out on most of
the dunya as well. Mediocrity
[Arabic recitation]
I only have one.